frieren für die freiheit
mutmaßlich gibt es klügere aufrufe
solidarität und empathie mit der ukraine
zu zeigen aber der krieg dort wird
konsequenzen für uns haben selbst wenn
uns das gas nicht ausgeht
wirtschaftsproduktion und wohlstand
werden leiten von leighton in mario pohl
und car kits sind wir trotzdem
lichtjahre entfernt max früh warnstufe
dreht putin den gashahn zu jetzt in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zu wächst im studio posselt ist bei uns
wirtschaftsjournalistin
hermann josef tenhagen ist chefredakteur
des gemeinnützigen verbraucher ratgebers
finanz tippt haben zugeschaltet sind uns
markus gürne der leiter der ard
börsenredaktion in frankfurt und frank
dietzsch ist bei uns vom deutschen
verein des gas- und wasserfaches das ist
der branchenverband der gas und
wasserwirtschaft sie zertifizieren sie
forschen für die gas und
wasserwirtschaft und sie entwickeln auch
ein regelwerk für diesen wichtigen
wirtschaftszweig gerne sollte putin den
gashahn doch noch zu drehen gehen dann
bei uns die lichter aus nein die lichter
werden nicht ausgehen aber die lichter
an zulassen dass wir deutlich teurer
werden das ist in jedem fall klar das
wird uns an ganz vielen ecken und enden
treffen das wird die privaten haushalte
treffen es wird in besonderem maße auch
die wirtschaft treffen das wird für uns
eine sehr teure veranstaltung werden
aber dieser konflikt hat natürlich auch
das wurde er schon vielfach besprochen
auch seinen preis
private haushalte werden wieder etwas
lernen müssen was wir von unseren eltern
oder großeltern schon mal gehört haben
hauszuhalten zu sparen gegen die nicht
unbedingt notwendig sind tatsächlich
auch ob das die heizung ist oder die
lichter mehr tatsächlich zu sparen und
die industrie wird an vielen ecken und
enden auch probleme bekommen wenn es
dann tatsächlich so kommen sollte und
das wird vor allen dingen mittel und
langfristig dann größere auswirkungen
haben weil wenn produkte dann auch nicht
mehr hergestellt können werden können
weil energie fehlt da wird es auch die
lieferketten in einer exportorientierten
wirtschaft wieder unseren empfindlich
treffen verwaltung
deutschland hat ja tatsächlich eine
robuste wirtschaft robuste finanzen
krisen bewerten sei den von der
finanzmarkt- und schuldenkrise 2008
unsere ökonomische widerstandsfähigkeit
müsste eigentlich groß sein
ja und nein also einmal haben wir ja
nicht nur die finanzkrise hinter uns
sondern wir haben auch die korona krise
gerade ökonomisch hinter uns aber die
hat uns ja auch ein jahr mit minus 4,8
prozent war wachstum gebracht und einen
schuldenberg der eben noch nicht
adressiert ist und die auch noch nicht
abgetragen ist insofern ist die
widerstandsfähigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft in den letzten drei jahren
nicht höher geworden sondern sie ist
niedriger geworden und man muss ja eben
glaube ich auch immer sagen und das
glaube ich ist ganz wichtig in so einer
diskussion sanktionen sollen ja
demjenigen schaden die man sanktionieren
will und sie sollen nach möglichkeit
möglichst wenig auf den zurückschlagen
der sanktioniert und das ist glaube ich
etwas worum im moment eben auch sehr
stark gerungen wird zu recht weil man
sich eben immer fragen muss kann man
sich weniger wachstum oder wie viel
weniger wachstum kann man will man und
muss man sich leisten
vielleicht eben auch vor dem hintergrund
dass wir eine rezession gerade hinter
uns gesagt hat auch uns dass die
sanktionen auch uns wehtun werden hätten
hagen markus grüner als gerade schon
angedeutet die preise die gehen gerade
durch die decke in vielen bereichen in
bei vielen produkten ist der verbraucher
eigentlich da weitgehend schutzlos
naja ist nicht komplett schutzlos aber
wenn die preise alle durch die decke
gehen bezahlen wir alle ein stück weit
und dann müssen wir gucken was wir
individuell ein stückweit dagegen tun
können also die frage können wir
tatsächlich mit weniger sprit
verbrauchen können wir bei unserer
heizung was machen dass wir weniger
energie brauchen können wir darauf
hinwirken also wir machen bei finanzen
solisten 25 tipps wie du weniger energie
brauchen kannst das ist das was man tun
kann man kriegt damit den energiepreis
nicht runter aber den weniger für
weniger verbrauch kommen dann machen und
anbieter danach auszuwählen dass sie
preiswerter sind kann man natürlich auch
mal und dann muss man auch auf in die
industrie gucken ich hab es vor ein paar
wochen schon mal gesagt gas oder heizöl
ist im westen deutlich preiswerter als
im osten beim heizöl macht das 30 40
cent pro liter aus ob man in am
niederrhein den heizöltank vollmacht
oder ob man das in brandenburg macht
die dieser notfallplan der ist jetzt
aktiviert worden die so genannte
frühwarn stufe noch ist ja nichts
passiert
wie muss man sich denn eigentlich diesen
mechanismus vorstellen wenn tatsächlich
die wenn es ernst wird wenn die krise
über uns hereinbricht da gibt es noch
zwei weitere stufen was passiert genau
könnten sie das kurz schildern
ja also mit der früh warnstufe ist
erstmal lediglich ein krisenteam
einberufen worden das aus experten
besteht aus der energiebranche also von
den fernleitungsnetzbetreiber von den
markt gebietsverantwortlichen und dann
eben entsprechend von der
bundesnetzagentur und die vorsitz hat
die das bundesministerium
wenn wir merken dass die last plus
situation sich physikalisch deutlich
ändert und wir keine marktbezogenen
maßnahmen mehr
nutzen können um ich sage mal die
situation stabil zu halten die
netzsituation stabil zu halten dann muss
man dann in die nächsten stufen schalten
und wenn man dann sozusagen in stufe 3
von 3 ist und wir tatsächlich eine
notfallsituation haben und die notfall
stufe ausgerufen wurde dann geht es
wirklich darum dass wir eine
mangelsituation haben und dass die
mangelsituation dann auch letztendlich
von einem sogenannten bundes
lastverteilung also von der
bundesnetzagentur
eben gemanagt werden muss in dem
krisenteam muss dann eben entschieden
werden ob es kürzungen bedarf und wie
die dann entsprechend umgesetzt werden
gut wir werden da gleich noch genauer
darauf eingehen was dafür branchen
betroffen sind sie das für die
privathaushalte aussieht für die
einzelnen unternehmen jetzt stellt sich
heute die frage
rollt nur noch der rubel oder reicht
auch noch euro für die bezahlung es geht
ja um die gaslieferungen
das sind etwas seltsame bankgeschäfte
die herr putin da gerade einleitet wie
ist es denn jetzt müssen wir jetzt in
rubel bezahlen oder können wir wie es
mario draghi und olaf scholz wohl
verstanden haben nach wie vor unser gas
mit euro bezahlen und das werden wir in
den nächsten tagen sehen ob er trank und
herr scholz das richtig verstanden haben
das weiß niemand so ganz genau aber
worauf worum es wohl geht ist eben die
frage wer am ende die devisen die ja für
ruf führt das gas bezahlt werden in
rubel umtauscht also auch das eben schon
diejenigen sind die bestellen oder ob es
eben diejenigen sind die das geld bei
der gazprombank das ist ja die bank über
die die meisten diese geschäfte
abgewickelt werden ob diejenigen sind
die das die dart bei dieser bank sitzen
und das geld dann eben nach russland
transferieren müssen oder sollen und
eben da die devise neben möglicherweise
dann
ja einzahlen oder der zentralbank geben
müssen die zentralbank hat ja in
russland er inzwischen sehr sehr
weitgehenden zugriff auf die gewiesen
die möglicherweise noch eingenommen
werden markus könne nicht alle deutschen
haben ja finanzwissenschaften studiert
das was wir gerade sehen und bzw gehört
haben aus moskau ist das wirklich einen
unterschied oder macht das was aus ob
man jetzt das in rubel fakturiert und
vorher in euro bezahlt hat ist das ein
taschenspielertrick ist das ein
buchungstrick oder geht es da schlicht
und einfach nur um das image des rubels
um das image russlands in der welt also
ich würde sagen taschenspielertrick
trifft das ganz gut das ist
wirtschaftspolitisches armdrücken was da
gerade passiert weil am ende geht es für
herrn putin ja offensichtlich einfach um
die frage zu sagen er braucht das geld
er möchte aber die hoheit über die
kommunikation haben wir da sagt ihr
müsst eigentlich ein sogenanntes p-konto
jetzt bei der gazprombank eröffnen da
könnt ihr dann ein zahlen in euro das
ist ja auch das was herr scholz er trage
so verstanden haben aber dort wird dann
konvertiert und bislang lief das haben
über ein anderes konto als wenn man ein
neues konto eröffnen muss dann habe ich
schon so den eindruck hier geht es in
aller erster linie mal um die hoheit in
der kommunikation um dann daraus eine
entsprechende propaganda aus russischer
sicht zu machen deshalb würde ich sagen
das ist ein klarer taschenspielertrick
es geht schon um ein bisschen mehr ja
merken den letzten zwei drei wochen
gesehen wieder rapide der rubel
verfallen der außenwert des rubel und
wie er dann wieder gestiegen ist und
letztlich ist ja auch vorstellbar dass
herr putin und die zentralbankchef in
dieses manöver benutzen wollen um den
rubel eben stabil zu halten um den
außenwert des rubel stabil zu halten
aber denken ich im leben dran den
gashahn zuzudrehen das weiß man nicht ob
die dame leben nicht dran denken ich
habe hier vor ein paar wochen gesessen
hat jemand gesagt im leben wird herr
putin nicht in die ukraine
einmarschieren und das wetter hat das
getan also ich glaube darauf da kann man
keine wetten machen aber dass da
möglicherweise eben mehr dahinter steckt
als nur arm drücken und dass man eben
nicht weiß ob am ende jemand daran denkt
den gashahn zuzudrehen oder nicht das
glaube ich muss man auch sagen zumal ja
eben immer noch auch die andere seite
auch offen ist also es gibt eben ja doch
viele nato-länder viele deiner des
westens die von deutschland erwarten
dass wir jetzt endlich den gashahn von
uns aus zu drehen und auch das ist
glaube ich etwas das im fortlauf des
krieges in der ukraine nicht so vom
tisch ist wie man jetzt so tut wenn man
darüber redet ob herr putin uns den
gashahn zum das richtig wäre es die
übernächste frage gewesen die nächste
herr könne
wir werden genau alles besprechen
könne noch sollte dieser gast ans serie
zweiter laufen also jetzt mit euro und
die werden dieser euro wird auf etwas
mysteriöse weise dann in rubel gewandelt
kann putin denn mit diesen
deviseneinnahmen weiterhin gut lebten
das war ja auch immer ein argument zu
sagen er könne eigentlich mit euro und
dollar im moment ziemlich wenig anfangen
stimmt das naja bei rubel ist es ja
relativ einfach rubel kann drucken wie
er will das ist die währung die in
russland vorherrscht mit devisen sie das
tatsächlich deutlich schwieriger aus und
wenn sie nur noch ein satz gestatten was
frau weidenfeller gerade gesagt hat
tatsächlich ist es entscheidend gewesen
in den letzten wochen wie stark die
schwankungsbreite des rubels war aber
das hängt natürlich auch damit zusammen
dass viele russische unternehmen ihre
devisen tauschen mussten um den rubel
stabil zu halten also diese diese
schwankungen die haben dann schon ein
paar gründe mehr tatsächlich aber es
bleibt dabei ist tatsächlich dass wir
für stellen russland ist abhängig
braucht die devisen in großem maße und
wenn sie über den gasverkauf
hereinkommen in welcher art und weise
auch immer dann ist das für russland
erst mal wichtig gut der andere fall
wäre wir würden von unserer seite aus
den gashahn zugedreht weil der druck
groß wird er ist ja groß auf deutschland
von verschiedenen verbündeten
nato-partnern wenn das passiert was
passiert dann ich sage mal fünf begriffe
die jeder kennt in jeder was anfangen
kann inflation rezession
arbeitslosigkeit weltwirtschaftskrise
börsencrash sind das alles
reaktionen wenn tatsächlich kein gas
mehr fließt egal wer jetzt diesen hahn
abgedreht hat es kommt nichts mehr es
fehlt uns gas aus russland macht noch 40
prozent der importe aus was passiert
naja es ist nicht zwangsläufig dass all
diese vokabeln eintreten und dass sie
innerhalb von drei stunden eintreten
also es muss nicht so eine art schwarzen
freitag geben sondern es kann eben auch
etwas moderator moderator ablaufen aber
alle szenarien die ich kenne sagen es
wird zu einem rückgang der
wirtschaftsleistung in diesem jahr
kommen und wir haben ja gestern erst die
wirtschaft den sachverständigenrat
gehört ja schon gesagt hat das wachstum
wird irgendwie maximal sogar 1,82
prozent liegen das heißt halt eben schon
jetzt ist das wachstum oder sind die
wachstumsaussichten für dieses jahr
reduziert wenn das gas nicht mehr
entweder gekauft wird oder verkauft wird
dann wird es eben ein minus geben am
ende des jahres vor dem wachstum - zwei
prozent sagen die einen 4 die anderen -
6 ist glaube ich das szenario was am was
so alles zusammenzählt was schief gehen
kann aber dass das ist eine menge und
das heißt also unabhängig davon wer
jetzt gerade den den teufel an die wand
malt aber es heißt eben höhere
arbeitslosigkeit oder viel höhere
kurzarbeit wieder und das ist auch sehr
teuer das darf man da darf man nicht so
tun als sei das irgendwie nur ein segen
das heißt dass ganze branchen in
deutschland ihre geschäftspläne
revidieren müssen vor allem die
chemische industrie darüber haben wir ja
schon gesprochen das heißt dass die
lieferketten fragiler werden als sie es
jetzt schon sind und das heißt eben
einfach rezession heißt
wohlstandsverlust also wir werden bei
einer sehr hohen inflation bei sehr
hohen energiepreisen bei sinkender
kaufkraft für die bevölkerung höhere
arbeitslosigkeit haben und kein wachstum
und das ist kein spaß unabhängig davon
ob es an einem tag in zwei stunden kraft
oder ob es moderator das ist ja die
frage wenn das alles passiert wenn die
inflation immer größer wird durch
rezession
unternehmenspleiten entstehen menschen
werden arbeitslos oder in kurzarbeit
geschickt die lieferketten sind
unterbrochen entweder weil die
infrastruktur nicht mehr funktioniert
oder weil bestimmte firmen nicht mehr
produzieren was kann man dagegen
eigentlich tun auch wieder gerade aus
verbrauchersicht welche staatlichen
hilfen sind dann nötig und für alle
möglichen dass das eine ist ja bei der
inflation gibt gilt wieder das gleiche
was was bei den energiepreisen gilt man
hat einen
werkzeugkasten immer selber benutzen
kann also vergleichen vergleichen
vergleichen tatsächlich so einkaufen mit
dem einkaufs buch und mit dem was man da
heute machen kann das kann man als bei
mama bei finanzfragen meiner liste das
zweite was man aber auf jeden fall dann
anschauen muss ist wen muss man denn im
zweifel helfen also ich mach das jetzt
noch mal mit diesem mit diesem sprit
hilfen die die bundesregierung vor zwei
wochen beschlossen hat die kosten
dreieinhalb milliarden in drei monaten
das sind über das jahr wenn man das
machen würde wenn das 14 milliarden
damit wir unseren sprit billiger haben
das ist mehr als der gesamte etat des
ministeriums für frauen familie senioren
und jugend damit wir und den sprit
billiger haben das heißt also das signal
ist doch eigentlich eindeutig wir werden
ganz vielen leuten helfen müssen die
brauchen dringend hilfe aber wir werden
doch deutlich gezielter da rangehen
müssen mit diesen staatlichen hilfen bei
sonst können wir uns diese art von von
von hilfen nicht leisten das heißt auf
der einen seite wir jeder der was tun
kann sollte was daran tun und die
anderen leben denen geholfen wenn muss
den muss geholfen denn und letzter satz
noch wir tun aber noch nicht so richtig
viel ich habe heute mittag mit einem
klempner der sozusagen im vertrieb von
so
heizungstechnik ist die
energieeinsparung machen gesprochen und
habe den gefragt aber bei dir rennt doch
wahrscheinlich rennen sie doch die bude
ein sagt nee rennen noch nicht die bude
ein es wird noch nicht die bude
eingerannt und genau so war es beim
sprit vor drei wochen da sind vor drei
wochen haben die leute angefangen diese
sprit apps zu benutzen die es seit
jahren gibt wo ich seit ich weiß nicht
fünf jahren darüber rede 300 prozent
zuwachs vor drei wochen also mit anderen
worten wir sind auch noch nicht in den
mode dass wir das was wir machen können
da wirklich nutzen verdient was passiert
denn jetzt in ihrer organisation dem
deutschen verein für das gas und
wasserfach sie müssen ja in einer
notfall wenn dieser not die notfall
stufe gezündet wird ja zum beispiel
entscheiden wer noch gas trägt und wer
nicht nach welchen kriterien gibt
es da gibt es welche oder haben sie da
auch ein spielraum bestimmte branchen
jetzt
bevorzugen weil das
empfindliche infrastruktur ist oder nach
welchen kriterien wird das dann gemacht
das muss ja auch relativ schnell gehen
ja wenn sie jetzt sagen notfall stufe
dann sind wir schon in der letzten stufe
und dann haben wir den bundes last
verteilt dann werden wir dann wird die
anweisung vom staat selber kommen aber
wir werden natürlich in dem gremium
zusammen entscheiden wie wir
letztendlich
wen wir kürzen und und wie wir kürzen
und da gibt es keine blacklist also wir
haben da jetzt nicht eine abschalten
folge wer zuerst dran kommt sondern wir
wissen dass aufgrund der physikalischen
lage im netz entscheiden wir müssen
gucken was bedeutet das für die
produktion ist es vielleicht gerade ein
lebenswichtiger bereich und das müssen
wir abschätzen weil das gesetz selber
ist eigentlich relativ simpel
aufgestellt wir haben geschützt und
nicht geschützte kunden und zu den
geschützten kunden gehören eigentlich
nur jene kunden die mit wärme versorgt
werden also der letztverbraucher dann
vielleicht noch kraftwerke die eben für
die wärmeversorgung da sind und soziale
einrichtungen wie krankenhäuser und
altenheime und alle anderen nicht
geschützten kunden das sind dann
diejenigen wo man dann sozusagen die
mangelsituation einschätzen muss
aufgrund der physikalischen lage
aufgrund der gegebenheiten aufgrund der
einspeise situation und dann kann es
eben maßgeblich sein dass man sagt man
würde den mangel eben über pro rata also
ratierlich daneben verteilen oder man
würde sogar dann sagen
je nach je nach abwägung ergebnis dass
man einen bestimmten kunden raus nimmt
oder eben nicht aber das kann man wie
gesagt nicht pauschal beantworten wir
haben da auch keine top ten ist
sozusagen das auch schon für die zweite
stufe die sogenannte erlagen stufe dass
da schon ausgewählt wird oder ist das
nur in der dritten stufe dann der fall
wenn ein nein in der in der früh
warnstufe wurde jetzt in der nächsten
stufe die man zünden kann die alarmstufe
da ist das nicht so da bin ich noch in
dem bereich wo ich mag basierte mittel
nutze das heißt ich kann speicher
anweisen ich bin noch in der
verantwortung dass der netzbetreiber
sozusagen die systemstabilität aufrecht
erhält der kann das überlasst
verlagerung machen der kann das über
externe und interne regelenergie machen
also er versucht sozusagen noch selber
das netz zu managen wenn er dann aber
merkt dass diese marktbasierten
maßnahmen nicht mehr ausreichen wenn der
mangel halt einfach zu groß ist wenn die
drücke an bestimmten punkten nicht mehr
aufrecht erhalten werden könnten dann
wäre wahrscheinlich auch der fall dass
man dann entsprechend in die nächste in
die letzte stufe in die notfall stufe
käme da wäre dann sozusagen der bundes
last verteiler dann am zug der daneben
wirklichen weist anweisungen macht und
der instrumentenkasten den hatte ich ja
gerade bekannt aber wir haben wie gesagt
keine keine blacklisten okay ich wollte
nur sagen dass das ist ganz wichtig dass
die haushalte wissen also die bude wird
nicht kalt das ist geschützt schulen
sind geschützt krankenhäuser sind
geschützt öffentliche einrichtungen
geschützt und wenn ich das richtig
verstanden hat man diesen § 53a glaube
ich im energiewirtschaftsgesetz gerade
geändert und gesagt auch kleine kleine
gewerbetreibende die das brauchen zum
heizen ihrer
ihres büros sind auch geschützt das
heißt es geht dann tatsächlich darum ob
man bestimmte industriezweige runter
fährt und ob man so macht wie bei corona
dass man sagt die kneipen müssen alle zu
machen und dann sagen würde man sagen
also diese industrie braucht besonders
viel gas die kann aber drei monate in
den laden zumachen dann müssen die drei
monate den laden zumachen das werden
dieses mal nicht die kneipen sei
möglicherweise automobil- chemie- oder
stahlindustrie markus gerne wenn dieser
fall den franck die stadt gerade
skizziert hat also dieser diese dritte
stufe notfall stufe gezündet wird was
bedeutet das zum beispiel für die börsen
was würde da wie würden die börsen
reagieren wenn wesentliche branchen die
ja unsere unsere wirtschaftskraft unser
bruttoinlandsprodukt ausmachen auch
exportstark sind also wie gesagt stark
daran beteiligt sind dass es dem land
gutgeht was passiert an den börsen also
grundsätzlich muss man sagen dass bisher
zumindest die börse obwohl sie 13
prozent nach unten gegangen ist seit
beginn des krieges sind es am ende
trotzdem nur 13 prozent also die
finanzmärkte haben sich doch insgesamt
als relativ widerstandsfähig erwiesen
dass es grundsätzlich wenn man in die
vergangenheit schaut bei geopolitischen
krisen grundsätzlich fast immer so
gewesen jetzt ist natürlich eine
situation noch einmal eingetreten wo die
unsicherheit wieder deutlich größer wird
und wir haben es ja vorher gehört sie
kriegen jede auch die härteste
wirtschaft und die widerstandsfähigste
wirtschaft klein wenn sie krisen
pausenlos in kurzer folge haben und ob
das finanzkrise war frauenfeld hat
angesprochen dann kam corona jetzt haben
wir ukraine dann wird das natürlich
schon auch deutliche auswirkungen haben
diese auswirkungen werden aber eher
nicht kurzfristig kommen so oder diese
auswirkungen das ist das gefährliche
eigentlich für die deutsche wirtschaft
daran die werden mittel- und langfristig
er tatsächlich folgen haben wenn
produktionsstopp ist wenn teile nicht
mehr kommen wenn lieferkette neben
zusammenbrechen dann ist die nachfrage
vielleicht dann noch da aber die
produktion kann eben nicht mehr starten
und das wird dann in der längeren phase
auswirkungen haben die uns sehr weh tun
werden und zwar nicht nur der wirtschaft
sondern auch volkswirtschaftlich enorm
tiefe spuren hinterlassen werden auch
wenn ich das noch ergänzen darf
natürlich noch einmal zusätzlichen schub
gibt es gibt also wenn man eine
situation hat in der die nachfrage der
kunden der konsumenten der unternehmen
untereinander hoch bleibt aber das
angebot schrumpft weil eben unternehmen
vom von der energieversorgung
abgeschnitten werden dann geht es eben
in eine preisspirale und dann haben wir
eben noch einmal einen zusätzlichen
schub für die inflation die ja ohnehin
schon wegen der energiepreise so
wahnsinnig gestiegen ist
jetzt haben wir gerade gehört die
bundesnetzagentur also der staat ist
dann in der entscheidende player in der
situation kein gas mehr kommt
bisher hat man ja immer erlebt das
mächtige einflussreiche industrien über
lobbyismus
versucht haben da einfluss zu nehmen ist
auch so ein gar nicht zu erwarten nach
dem motto wir sind wichtiger als die
anderen jetzt nicht die die sowieso
schon vorzugs werden wie privathaushalte
kleine gewerbetreibende kritische
infrastruktur sondern alle anderen wie
muss man sich das vorstellen da bleibt
für die bliebe ja vielleicht auch etwas
übrig aber eben nicht mehr für alle naja
ich meine da wird das wettbewerb geben
da wird es natürlich viele geben die
werden es versuchen und argumentieren
dafür zu werben dass sie nicht vom netz
genommen werden oder nicht solange oder
dass man eben das doch bitte gleichmäßig
auf alle verteilt das ist übrigens nicht
nur ein wettbewerb der innerhalb der
unternehmens stattfinden wird sondern
der natürlich auch europäisch
stattfindet nicht also weil es geht ja
nicht nur darum dass deutschland
möglicherweise vom gasnetz
abgeschnitten wird und von den
russischen gaslieferungen sondern das
werden andere länder europas auch das
tut anderen ländern europas auch
passieren und dann wird es eben auch
europäisch natürlichen gerangel darum
geben wer bekommt denn eigentlich dass
wer bekommt das gas was da ist zu
welchem preis insofern würde also glaube
ich es gibt wird natürlich gerangel
geben also wohl auf unternehmerischer
ebene als auch auf europäischer ebene
aber letztlich ist ja klar wenn kein gas
mehr im netz ist und wir haben das ja
gerade gehört wenn der druck abfällt
wenn das netz nicht mehr stabil ist dann
dann wird last abgeworfen das macht man
ja
heute gelesen habe dass die breite
verarbeiten die industrie sich schon zu
wort gemeldet hat also wir sollten wir
brauchen gas weil wir stellen müsli und
haferflocken
also das heißt diese kein witz satire
kann ich meine ich würde doch jeder
jetzt kommen viele wird man sagen aber
wir stellen uns überzeugt ich produkte
her oder wir stellen wir sorgen dafür
dass der
und entsprechend hart ist das ring und
das ist nicht nur lobbyismus wald
sondern es ist ja so dass man in einer
volkswirtschaft die produkte die
hergestellt werden die finden ja ihre
kunden und das sind ja eben nicht nur
matchbox autos sondern das sind
nahrungsmittel das sind die maschine
waren ja genau diese aber diese also
eigentlich deshalb mache ich mein ja nur
dass deshalb zu recht darum gestritten
wird eigentlich ist aber doch die logik
wenn man das jetzt anschaut eine relativ
einfache wir müssen gucken dass wir
möglichst wenig gas brauchen um die
speicher im herbst möglichst voll zu
haben damit wir noch einen
industriezweig mehr mit über die runden
kommt selbst wenn hochhuth in den
gashahn zudreht das heißt also master
erste maßgabe müsste ja jetzt sagen so
früh wie möglich alle einsparpotenziale
die da sind zu erschließen den leuten zu
sagen wenn ihr was ein sparen könnt also
den leuten den verbrauchern hier ist die
hilfe tempolimit sonntagsverkauf wohl
hier hier ist die hilfe damit ihr das
tut den industriezweigen die da
betroffen hier ist die hilfe damit dir
jetzt etwas was tut man wenn man das
heizen anschaulich ganz platt gesagt
zwischen erster november und 31 märz
sind 75 prozent der heizleistung in
seinem privaten haushalt verheizt wir
heizen jetzt nicht mehr ab april das ist
also april bis november da passiert
nichts das heißt also wir können jetzt
also als verbraucher zwischen jetzt und
dem november nichtstun durch verbrauch
oder sehr wenig jedenfalls auf der
us-seite wir können natürlich beim
benzin da kann man eine menge tun aber
auf der gass hat er nicht viel das heißt
jetzt müssten ab jetzt muss die
industrie die verbraucher die über den
sommer förderung selber ran und gucken
was man tun kann neben dem beschaffen
und ab dem und ab dem november alles das
was wir jetzt tun können an
sparmaßnahmen die im november greifen
für die privaten heizung also für
vermieter für leute die es selber machen
können alles das was wir da an den staat
bekommen hilft uns im winter über die
runden zu kommen und vielleicht auch dem
ein oder anderen müsli hersteller ende
gut also es gibt ja auch mit heizöl
deswegen habe ich das mit dem tempolimit
und dem sonntags fahrverbot
genannt es gibt also genügend
möglichkeiten hertie schließt sie das
eigentlich aus das heißt jetzt immer die
speicherseen moment glaube ich nur zu 26
prozent gefüllt im durchschnitt in
deutschland das heißt so wenig
eigentlich für den nächsten winter
müssen das eigentlich 90 prozent zu
beginn des winters sein wir müssen also
eine menge gas in den nächsten sechs
monaten organisieren wo kommt das
eigentlich her ist das realistisch zu
sagen sie ja ich glaube ich sogar eine
gesetzliche vorgabe jetzt dass wir im
oktober wieder mit 90 5 ständen in den
vier riesen speichern in deutschland
rechnen können
genau sie haben das gerade richtig
angesprochen wir haben wir jetzt ein
gesetzentwurf vorliegen und das gesetz
soll jetzt noch durch den bundesrat
verabschiedet werden und ist dann zum
ersten fünften sozusagen offiziell
verkündet und dort sind bestimmte für
gerade vorgegeben und den speicherausbau
den betreiben wir jetzt also sie haben
gerade richtig gesagt 26 ist der
speicher für stand gerade jetzt das ist
im vergleich zu den vorigen jahren ganz
normal wir sind eben jetzt am ende des
wirtschaftsjahres das neue gas
wirtschaftsjahr fängt jetzt zum ersten
april an und wir müssen zusehen dass wir
eben bis zum 18 erst 10 dann 80 prozent
und zum ersten 12 daneben entsprechend
90% füllstand haben den füllstand werden
wir aufbauen natürlich ganz normal durch
unser netz selber also unser
unser leitungsnetz das sind über 550
tausend kilometer die wir da unter der
erde haben die sind ein großer röhren
speicher und wir haben eben wie sie
gerade schon richtig gesagt haben gerade
jetzt in der warmen zeit eben nicht mehr
den heizbedarf sondern eher den die
industrie abnahme das heißt wir können
alleine schon über diesen netz puffer
sehr viel einspeichern wir hoffen uns
auch dass wir natürlich durch die
zusätzlichen lieferungen über
verflüssigtes erdgas die über tanker com
lng dass wir dort entsprechend auch noch
weitere mengen dazu bekommen um eben den
speicher entsprechend zu füllen die
essen wir haben kein eigenes kann ja
eher die frage war ist das realistisch
diesen jetzt aus heutiger sicht
realistisch diesen füllstand zu
erreichen nächsten im kommenden herbst
wir werden alles dafür tun dass wir den
füllstand erreichen ja
es gibt vielleicht noch einen kleinen
ausflug in einen anderen bereich noch
markus gürne es geht ja nicht nur um
gasimporte aus russland und aus der oder
über die ukraine die angeblich noch
laufen sollen es geht ja auch um die
lieferung von getreide von ölen von
metallen auch da sind ja große
lieferengpässe werden befürchtet hat
jetzt mit dem gas ursächlich nichts zu
tun aber hat möglicherweise
ähnliche konsequenzen auf was müssen wir
uns in diesem bereich das sind ja alles
produkte die wir dringend brauchen
das müssen wir aufpassen müssen uns in
diesem bereich einstellen also auch da
gilt entsprechend dass es wird mangel
geben es wird deutlich steigende preise
geben die werden übrigens andere
kontinente andere teile der wirtschaft
noch viel härter treffen tatsächlich uns
geht es ja da vergleichsweise noch gut
für uns wird es teuer werden und wie man
jetzt in den supermärkten auch sehen
kann ja was kann auch sein dass speiseöl
mal rationiert wird aber es hat ja vor
allen dingen mit der reaktion der leute
zu tun aber
tatsächlich geht bei den nahrungsmitteln
ähnliches wie beim gas und das hängt
üben übrigen auch zusammen vorher wird
wurde ja die chemische industrie auch
angesprochen die braucht extrem viel gas
weil sie stellt ganz viele teile her
eben nicht nur für den maschinenbau
nicht nur für autohersteller
sondern tatsächlich auch für die
ernährungsindustrie oder für die
pharmaindustrie also da gehören die
dinge auch tatsächlich zusammen das sind
an vielen stellen kommunizierende röhren
und die auswirkungen werden immer
ähnlich sein es wird mangel geben und es
wird deutlich teurer wert mit den
auswirkungen die wir jetzt schon sehen
und wahrscheinlich noch zu nehmen
da glaube ich ihnen schon auch sagen
muss natürlich ist eben nicht nur der
verbraucher
irrational bei einer daneben auf einmal
vier oder fünf flaschen speiseöl kauft
sondern die märkte sind ja auch
irrational also die erwartungen oder die
befürchtungen die man hat für zum
beispiel getreide lieferungen aus der
ukraine
da muss ich ehrlich sagen wir haben
keinen und getreide aus der ukraine
wurde nichts aus dem aus der ukraine 50
australien und sonst nicht die
getreidespeicher sind voller trotzdem
gehen die preise hoch ja und ich glaube
dass da eben also dann hat natürlich
total recht wenn er sagt das ist für
andere kontinente ein riesengroßes
problem weil eben da auch in devisen
gezahlt werden muss weil das arme länder
sind afrika lateinamerika die werden
ganz ganz andere probleme haben aber ich
wollte nur darauf hinweisen dass
natürlich auch die die märkte jetzt für
gas für öl für getreide für kupfer die
drehen ja auch durch weil sie eben auch
alle angst davor haben dass es da
knappheiten gibt
möglicherweise werden eben diese
preisausschläge dann in den nächsten
zwei drei vier fünf wochen gar nicht so
enorm sein wie wir im moment annehmen
aber dass es eben eine große
herausforderung ist und dass die risiken
sehr sehr groß sind das ist völlig klar
in so viele staatliche
stützungsmaßnahmen nötig sind hermann
josef tenhagen hat das ja gerade schon
gesagt das bedeute dass der staat noch
viel tiefer in die tasche greifen muss
und das heißt der schuldenstand wird
steigen und die schuldenbremse können
wir auch für 2023 und 24 ist ehrlich
gesagt total gefährlich also ich glaube
da geht es weniger um die frage der
schuldenbremse 2023 2024 sondern wir
haben ja schon in diesem jahr eine ganz
merkwürdige geschichte dass wir einen
bundeshaushalt vorliegen haben der super
sauber aussieht und ganz elegant gemacht
ist und eine verschuldung unter 100
milliarden hat aber wir haben 24
sondervermögen und sonderhaushalte in
denen die schulden versteckt werden wir
haben einen ergänzungs haushalt der
jetzt im april vorgelegt werden wird in
dem eben möglicherweise das was was wir
eben diskutiert haben also die
benzinpreis zuschüsse und die energie
zuschüsse
verzeichnet werden aber wir wissen
eigentlich nicht wenn wir den
bundeshaushalt anschauen wie steht denn
eigentlich deutschland jetzt da also wie
hoch ist die belastung die wir jetzt
schon auf der uhr haben und das wird in
den nächsten zwei drei jahren eben im
zweifel eher schlimmer als besser und
wenn sich der bundesfinanzminister nicht
entschließt das jetzt eben endlich auch
mal in den haushalt suchen zu schreiben
dass man es lesen kann dass man das
verstehen kann dass das parlament
darüber abstimmen kann das parlament hat
das haushaltsrecht dann ist das eben
auch aus ich würde mal sagen aus
staatspolitischen gründen eine kritische
kritische geschichte wenn es um magie
geht und auch dann die soziale
gerechtigkeit wieder eine rolle spielt
heißt immer so schön die stärkeren
schulter soll dann mehr tragen als die
schwächeren wie könnte das denn aussehen
stichwort umverteilung von von kaufkraft
an krisen
ja das habe ich meine der eine punkt ist
wir haben ja wir haben tatsächlich einen
interessanten effekt wir haben 2020 und
2021 die höchsten sparquoten der
geschichte der republik hat 15 16
prozent das heißt jedenfalls ein teil
der bevölkerung in deutschland ist in
der lage relativ viel geld zur seite zu
legen um zu sparen der andere nicht das
ist schlägt so ein bisschen in die
gleiche kerbe wie eben zu zu gucken wer
braucht denn dringend hilfe und wenn man
wenn man sagt man möchte das nicht über
schulden finanziert dann muss man den
leuten sagen dann müssen halt müssen
heute mehr steuern gezahlt wenn es
werden übrigens ja schon mehr steuern
gezahlt über die mehrwertsteuer kommt
der ganze menge mehr rein bei jeder
inflation erfreut sich der
finanzminister jedenfalls ein bisschen
auch über diese zahlungen in der
mehrwertsteuer also noch mal angucken
und dann muss man auch verteilungen
angucken aber wichtig ist wenn man nicht
so viel geld hat dann muss man
zielgenauer hingehen und bei einer
geschichte also es war ja ganz
interessant diese es gibt ja zwei
fraktionen von ökonomen die darüber
nachgedacht haben ob wir denn jetzt den
gashahn zugedreht haben können ob wir
das verkraften können bei beiden taucht
aber das ganze interessant also gerade
bei denen die sagen das können wir alles
machen da steht dann mittendrin ersten
mal muss den armen leuten aber dann
helfen und zweitens der staat möge doch
bitte die energiepreise so hoch halten
die es irgend geht damit die anpassung
von wirtschaft industrie schneller geht
weil nur mit hohen energiepreisen würde
das funktionieren und das was da drin
steht da wird ja nicht so laut drüber
geredet aber das ist natürlich dass wenn
ich mir nicht als industrieunternehmen
so was höre dann frage ich mich meinen
die das ernst und wenn die das ernst
meinen wann kann ich anfangen weil dann
muss ich ja strukturell da sein also das
passiert ja nicht das hört ja nicht im
nächsten winter auf dass er das
eigentliche problem wenn wenn wir jetzt
unseren so eine gas zum gasstopp haben
dann müssten all die strukturellen
geschichten die wir sowieso am horizont
haben weil wir das russische gas ja
langfristig nicht an die schnelle
reinigung müssen wir müssen schneller
dann passieren und dann klimaziele
kommen noch dazu also das muss dann
alles schneller passieren und das ist
die eigentliche herausforderung wie wir
das so hinkriegen dass die leute dann
damit gehen und nicht das gefühl haben
nur die anderen profitieren und sie sind
diejenigen die da drauf zahlen es gibt
natürlich zur steuererhöhungen gibt es
auch alternativen und zur umverteilung
man kann eben zum beispiel sagen wir
machen wir hoffen dass das wachstum
relativ schnell danach wieder anzieht
sagen dass wir jetzt den aufschwung das
dritte mal vertagen und man kann
natürlich eben natürlich auch darüber
reden ob man die schuldenbremse nicht
noch mal ein oder zwei jahre aussetzt in
einer solchen krise und man kann und
muss glaube ich auch darüber reden dass
der staat in den letzten jahren sich
ausgaben ans bein geschafft hat dir
besser nicht sich ans bein geschafft
hätte und auch da muss man glaube ich
dann irgendwann mal hingucken und jene
aus allerdings auch hat könnten wir
jetzt noch eine ganze menge von ausgaben
ausgabeposten aufzählen von bundeswehr
ist bis klimaschutz markus gürne
wir haben ja eine veritable rohstoff und
energiekrise was lernen wir eigentlich
daraus für die zukunft dass wir uns
möglichst nie mehr von einem einzigen
lieferanten so abhängig machen ist das
klar oder ich denke jetzt schon mal an
das thema seltene erden das kommt
eigentlich fast nur aus china auch kein
staat der uns sehr freundlich gesinnt
ist was lernen wir aus dieser sozusagen
willentlich willentlichen abhängigkeit
die da über jahre hinweg entwickelt
worden ist aus russland ein großteil
unseres erdgases und erdöls zu beziehen
naja ich hoffe dass wir vor allen dingen
fehler nicht noch mal wiederholen das
haben wir ja in corona zeiten auch schon
gesehen dass auch da abhängigkeit ein
ziemlich großes problem waren das ist
jetzt wieder so diesmal bei rohstoffen
das bedeutet auch all das was hier
gerade schon angesprochen wurde
tatsächlich dinge müssen auch
beschleunigt werden ist die große frage
wie macht man das der staat hat
begrenzte mittel hat auch manche
unpopuläre maßnahmen die man treffen
kann auf der anderen seite hat uns die
bundesbank erklärt im vergangenen juli
es gibt sieben billionen euro
privatvermögen in deutschland vielleicht
muss man auch sich angucken wie schafft
man es die etwas mehr so zu aktivieren
dass man die verschiedenen politischen
gesellschaftspolitischen ziele die man
erreichen möchte auch erreichen muss und
ich denke was schon auch ein wichtiges
thema ist und das geht auch in richtung
abhängigkeiten dass wir an vielen
stellen abhängigkeiten grundsätzlich
verringern müssen weil ich denke dass
uns auch china in der nächsten zeit noch
beschäftigen wird der schulterschluss
jetzt an vielen politischen stellen mit
russland der muss einem zumindest
dahingehend auch zu denken geben dass
der chinesische markt ein sehr sehr
großer ist und auch die abhängigkeit
chinas im umgekehrten fall von europa
ist deutlich größer als man das so
gemeinhin glaubt weil china möchte vor
allen dingen auch 1 um den wohlstand im
eigenen land hoch zu halten seine
produkte verkaufen und ich glaube da ist
die russische kundschaft auch in zukunft
nicht mehr ganz so kaufkräftig auf dank
der sanktionen wie man das in china
gerne hätte und deshalb ist es auch für
china wichtig seine produkte nach europa
zu verkaufen ich habe noch eine frage
was jetzt die gasversorgung aus russland
angeht wir haben ja angst davor dass das
gas nicht mehr kommt viele haben angst
davor aus guten gründen wir haben ja
jetzt besprochen in letzten 40 minuten
kann man eigentlich wenn jetzt wir kein
gas mehr abnehmen wir könnten ja selbst
das embargo gegenüber russland errichten
und sagen wir neben gras nicht mehr ab
was machen die russen dann eigentlich
mit dem gas kann man so ein gasfeld
einfach so abstellen oder was passiert
dann eigentlich
jeder die russen haben ja schon
angekündigt also wir können ja auch den
chinesen unser gas verkaufen wenn ihr es
nicht mehr haben wollte
ja das könnten sie machen wenn die
gasfelder natürlich mit dem chinesischen
netz angeschlossen werden was sie aber
zum teil nicht sind also sie können uns
natürlich sozusagen den hahn
buchstäblich abdrehen das ventil zu
machen und dann haben wir sozusagen ein
jahren röhren speicher der stehendes gas
hat wo dann irgendwann der druck abfällt
wenn man nichts machen würde das problem
haben sie aber gerade schon richtig
erkannt und angesprochen die
produktionsanlagen die können eben nicht
so ohne weiteres abgestellt werden das
heißt da müsste man im zweifel dann
wirklich werte vernichten also das heißt
man müsste das gas dann auf die fackel
legen und verbrennen oder aber wenn man
keine wenn man noch andere abnehmer
strukturen hat das dann eben an diese
abnehmer strukturen weiter zu leiten das
wäre china das wäre indien aber wie ich
schon gesagt hat nicht alle gasfelder
sind eben anders
mit mit china und mit mit mit dem
indischen netz verbunden und wenn man so
ein so eine gas förderanlage eben
entsprechend schließt dann kann man sie
unter umständen dann nicht mehr wieder
nutzen also da muss man sie wirklich
versiegeln und zu machen und dann hat
man im prinzip auch da letztendlich den
wert vernichtet und kann nichts mehr
damit anfangen das heißt also gut ist
möglicherweise gar nicht in einer so
starken position mit dem gas lassen sie
uns noch mal ganz kurz was markus gerne
gaal noch erwähnt hat auch schon das
corona gezeigt hat da wurden die
lieferketten die globalen lieferketten
ziemlich demoliert jetzt in der folge
des ukraine krieges zeigt sich unsere
fatale abhängigkeit von fossilen
energien
umso wichtiger ist eine energiewende
sind wir am ende einer globalisierung
wie wir sie bisher hatten müssen wir
entweder globalisierung neu denken neu
definieren oder ist das das ende der
globalisierung
also ist es auf jeden fall eine sehr
kritische phase und die ist aber nicht
jetzt erst angefangen und auch nicht mit
corona angefangen sondern wir sehen ja
schon seit der finanzkrise dass die
handelsverflechtungen zurückgehen also
dass das wirtschaftswachstum schneller
höher ist als der handel und das zeigt
ja eben das im grunde schon so die
globalisierung irgendwo stattfindet wir
sehen dass jetzt auch wieder und in der
tat ist es eben so dass diese erwartung
die die man eben immer hatte das
sozusagen die weltordnung auch die welt
friedensordnung verknüpft ist mit einer
weltwirtschaftsordnung die wohlstand und
demokratie und menschenrechte also das
was egon bahr mal wandel durch handel
genannt hat dass das eben funktioniert
und intakt ist diese vorstellung ist
spätestens jetzt zerbrochen und ob man
das eben wieder errichten kann und wie
man es wieder errichten kann ist eine
ganz große frage die vor allem
deutschland beschäftigen sollte weil
deutschland ist die offenste
volkswirtschaften unter allen
entwickelten volkswirtschaften abhängig
ein ende der globalisierung markus gürne
eine deutliche veränderung auf jeden
fall das schlichte frau weidenfeld
vollkommen bei es wird nicht nur eine
kritische phase jetzt sein sondern wir
werden eine sehr lange kritische phase
erleben und auch an vielen stellen
veränderungen der pole wie wir sie
bisher kannten gut das war das
schlusswort der sendung zu dem thema wie
gehen hier jetzt mit den gaslieferungen
um was kriegen wir noch brauchen das
überhaupt noch das wird uns auch in den
nächsten monaten beschäftigen ich
bedanke mich bei uns arbeiten fällt bei
hermann josef tenhagen bei markus gürne
und bei frank dietsche liebe zuschauer
die nächste phoenix gesprächssendung
dieser montag um 22.15 unter den linden
moderiert von michaela kolster da geht
es unter anderem auch um die
energiesicherheit jetzt folgt phoenix
der tag mit thomas bade da geht es noch
mal um die äußerung von wladimir putin
zu den gaslieferungen und wie die
bezahlt werden sollen bleiben sie bei
uns
[Musik]